on this week's show what exactly is a
lease option agreement and how do you
secure one in the news we discover how
estate agents are misleading their
clients and type in hired commissions
and we show you tips on how to avoid
this and we'll also be answering your
property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost late I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to this week's episode of
the property investors podcast it's
gonna be a good show this week I think
so were to delve it into the lease
options yep the estate agent news story
isn't it I know it's good I'm looking
forward to getting into that but before
we get started what we've built to this
way highlight of the week go highlight
of the week okay so we went on a
team-building exercise
and we went go carton did you win no did
she not know didn't you used to be a
like drama the drama of Lewis Hamilton
and stuff no not driven by Lewis
Hamilton no I I done carting for like 12
years and I was a pretty good I mean the
same team as him no you just tell me
that when we were out one night show off
no tell me about these talents okay no I
know he used to recently same soccer
that used to go to yeah right house and
they wasn't at the same time yes so he
have race doing that no I'm not race for
him with different races but he was it
same vain you when he was carting like
ten years like when he was caught racing
like maybe 12 13 years ago okay that
sounds just like me saying that I live
in the same country as him pretty much
this is not very impressive at all
but it's like we're in the same vicinity
but okay so you you've just been near
Lewis house yeah that's it I think I I
think I I think he credits me for some
of his talent okay
that's not quite an aggressive he's just
being in the vicinity of Lewis how
pretty much suddenly nowhere near is but
interestingly it was quite fun karting
like you missed out because you are not
a team player
No
I think um now you were not very well
but it was very fun Nick and Nick came I
wasn't unwell I just did want to come
Nick was quite quick you know was oh
he's not quick it's setting up the
cameras but he was quickly carting did
he did he be yeah he didn't actually
know they wasn't that quick he's still
quite quick
Glen really yeah the Dark Horse that
glad isn't well go ahead right after the
first race he come out and he said I'll
sleep was I need some help
it was can help me so I gave him a
little bit of advice on what he was
doing wrong and then he went out and he
just completely ignored all the all the
warning flags there was a big crash and
I think Samuel caused a bit of a pileup
and Glen was just like just draw through
everybody just kept going when everyone
else stopped and he won by about a lap
okay awesome
so Lisa have you been up to what vibing
up so I've I've just been working I'm
particularly exciting to be honest it's
just been non-stop non-stop work but
it's good it's good but I need been
caught in so I thought I thought you
don't what I'm shocked you didn't win I
was shocked I was fastest but I just
because I was obeyed the rules and it's
been working and drinking classy classy
coffee
minguk Kaffee nothing but coffees you
can say sorry so lease options yeah it's
just this turn or how unprofessional my
mistake before I criticized too much and
we just double-check yeah my is on
silent how I'm professional so at least
option agreements someone asked me to
sum up what a lease option was in 20
seconds the other day and this is the
way this is the way I described yeah
okay so will you buy a car on HP you
take ownership of the car but then you
don't buy it for a few years and you've
got the option to either give it them
back or you can keep it at least option
is the same but with a house exactly so
you take ownership of the house you want
the option to buy it in a few years but
if you don't want you can just given the
house back yep so it's actually very
good sum up yeah
so moving on so that's that's that's
what a lease options okay so that's what
a lease option is so we thought we would
talk a little about how you actually go
and get one of these
yeah good knowing that the problem is is
that you can't go to an you know the car
it's easy you go to a garage and they're
like yeah we do HP whereas with you
can't go to an estate agents and go
clear me a lease option please I want
that house I want to pay it
interestingly most estate agents don't
know what this is mmm-hmm they have no
idea what lease options are
they've never heard of them they have no
idea about the concept you can get them
through lease options through a stage
and you can get lease options to estate
agents I've done it and it's it's a lot
harder because you have to I say there's
a law properties are people's business
once you get to know the person at that
state agents then the deals will come so
I've secured a lease option through in a
stage and I've just paid them their fee
so they're not missing out so you
definitely can't do it by far the
easiest way to do it is direct a vendor
mmm-hmm but then again most people don't
most sort of everyday sort of vendors
don't really know what lease options are
and mostly when you first brought to
subject the guard goes off there like
this like no way it sounds dangerous
I've never heard of it it's probably a
scam or a corn and in reality we just
have to sort of take a step back do you
think partly that's the way that you
explain it do you think if you do think
if you explained it as simply as hi
Burgess they might be like maybe that
kind of makes maybe I think a lot of
people are programmed to have their
guard up straight away and they just
think cause they don't understand or
know where they switch off from it very
very early on so I know saengil teaches
very most secure and lease options you'd
never secure the money on the day you
never secure there and then you always
give the vendor plenty of time and you
always advise them to speak to the
solicitor so they know the the legal
aspect of it it's not just a case of
senior this just have a little hand
written contract whip dot yeah I'm gonna
take control your housing to pay for it
five years if I want to it's not like
that yeah the process is just like
buying a house it can take three months
it's non-live in a process yeah makes
sense I think that the the solicitor
part is Cape 100% I know why do you
think it's okay
because it's legal aspect because two
reasons first reason one you want to
make sure that the vengers protect it
yeah and if they know their legal
standpoint
and you don't want them not really you
don't want them going to a deal not
knowing what they're getting involved in
yeah you want them to know the fill in
the notes of the legal the legal side of
it and secondly if in five years time
that property value goes up and you've
agreed to sit let's just say like my
example I've got a property owned lease
option I've got secured for eighty two
thousand pound in five years time now
it's already worth around about that so
in five years time let's just say it's
worth 110 120 thousand pound the last
thing I want is the vendor then same to
me actually I'm not going to sell it to
you because it's now gone up by thirty
thousand pound because at the minute and
for the last three or four years they've
been desperate to get out at this house
so they cannot have it both their own
ways they can't have you we can't come
along and help them now and relieve them
of that pressure and situation for them
to this year thanks very much for
sorting all out for me we're also going
to have this there's got to be benefit
for both people so what I recommend
whenever you're doing a lease option is
is lot it's got to be good for both
parties so my particular this this
example have just shared with you in
five years time there's a profit share
in it so the vendor gets a profit share
I'm on it
I'm not going into details but there's a
they do get a profit share so if there's
anything a little profit you know no
it's it's enough that they're happy it's
three percent so if whatever the uplift
is I'll pay thirty percent of that so if
it goes over 100 grand they get 30 grand
because of Tangerang they get three
grams yeah but and what are you gonna do
you gonna ream or widget to give them
that money or I'll work out that when we
get to this at that point but they'll
get built they will get that money I'll
buy that house off him for a 30 percent
higher them so I'm buy 42 grand if it's
gone up to 100 that difference they'll
be getting at the round so 30% slight 10
yeah yes and the reason we've done that
and the reason they're happy with that
is because I've spent a considerable
amount money on the property so if I do
pull out that property I've reformed
their property for them so for them yeah
I do it's a good deal for them they've
got out of a situation that they were in
a bad situation
prop
was not rented out for eight months I've
taken a property on I've done all the
work don't work I've done everything
which cost quick just under ten thousand
pound
mmm they couldn't afford to do it yeah
they were paying a mortgage every month
they couldn't afford I've relieved them
of all of that I've invested in the
property yeah and I'm gonna buy it off
in the five years and I'm gonna give
them a percentage of the uplift Wow well
he goes let's go through its quickly if
you just list a point then we'll go
through okay so solicitor point first
will protects them from you know you
being dodgy or whatever second it
protects you yeah because in five years
five years time if they they go this is
the big one for us do it it protects
protects us because if you're five years
time they go oh I didn't I didn't
realized what I was signing us but we'll
you had a third you implied your own
sister legally represented you so you
idiot actually no so that's important so
they're the main two reasons but let's
go through the steps because any any
deal whether it be a property deal of
business deal any deal has gotta be a
win for both sides I think so yeah a lot
of people say hmm whiner
I thought I saw someone post is today on
the Facebook group wine earth would
anyone want to do a lease option
agreement I saw that you saw as well
okay so let's let's go into the into
that first a wine earth would anyone
want to do lease option agreement like
why would what when they could just sell
it okay why would they can I give you a
true life example yeah my property I've
got one property that this 82,000 pound
one yeah right they bought the property
at the height of the boom sort of 2006
2007 yeah they actually bought it in
2006 and they paid high because that's
when the property market was high they
paid top dollar for that property the
the the property crash happened property
prices have gone down they are stuck in
a situation where they they're negative
equity considerably
they live okay just for anyone who
doesn't know [ __ ] that know that neg
negative equity is where the all more on
the property than it's worth
yeah so for instance they or they have a
mortgage of 90,000 pound but the true
market value is only about eighty
thousand pounds so they're in ten
thousand PO negative so if they sell the
property like they literally lose money
lose money yeah
you know um these in the the the the
people who own this property the lovely
couple they live down in East Sussex it
bought this property up north because
they thought it was a nice easy
investment cheap houses because they
used to houses it for four five hundred
thousand pound and they they invented it
out they were not they didn't really do
it properly so they were not rented I go
through an estate agent there arranged
an ID by putting P adverts and papers
and just dealing with the tenants
themselves but they were trying to do
that from afar and they were not really
interested in the property apart from
going to see it was over years it was
very difficult for them they probably
got trashed
they ended up refurb Anette then
literally they just locked a property up
in its at empty for I think it was six
to eight months
it was empty with no tenants for about a
year year and a half and I and they're
just haven't paid their mortgage every
move I make it a loss on it and making a
loss to pay the mortgage and the pain
council tax as well so I had to M
without property what I had to do was I
actually went to view the property
because it was advertised on Rightmove
and it was a good deal great great
location for a HMO and I went to view it
and I put an offer in offer was accepted
but then they couldn't actually accept
the offer they accepted it but they
couldn't fulfill that so what happened
was they the they accepted it we went
through all the searches done all that
sort of stuff and then we got
notification by the agents by our
solicitors that they pulled out there
the reason they pulled out was because
the mortgage company put a stop to them
selling the house because the when-
acting he couldn't pay that balance off
so the mortgage company wanted to know
how they were gonna clear that balance
before they would allow them to sell the
house so they had to pull out because
they couldn't afford to find that to be
that difference um so then I basically I
bit of a ninja sort of there I love it I
love it when you first himself was a
ninja but yeah go on bit of ninja
research and a bit of due diligence it
managed to find the vendors I managed to
track the actual vendors done and we
couldn't make them we got chattin this
works for them and we ended up sitting
down with one see a paper what do you
want what do I want what can we do
yeah let's get this drawing up legally
bang let's get it so the first thing you
need you need people then who either
can't sell their property now because
every nate- a gente so they can't sell
it or they can tell you now but they
will for whatever reason don't need the
money
yeah so let's say for example they got
it as an inheritance I mean they're just
you know Russian so on someone this
doesn't need or can't get access to them
away from selling it that's who you
that's who you're looking for
so for these guys for example it's a win
because they literally they they don't
want to look after his house anymore
yep they don't want to be landlords a
lot of people don't wanna be landlords
we we look at it and go just rent it out
and just using the stage but some people
aren't wired like that and they're just
not interested so if they'd
don't want to be a landlord and they've
got this house whether it's been in his
inheritance or whether they've bought it
and then they're just don't want to do
it anymore
whatever it whatever it is amazing
television puts people off a lot of
things like a lot of these people just
watch these nightmare programs on TV
about tenants and they just keep it off
of them and they're just not cut out be
landlords yeah yeah so you're looking
for people like that and then basically
you're gonna because they will get more
money in the long term I know they will
the agreement we've got whether this
property is because I'm rent and I was
hm all I've compared to that with their
permission and the company the mortgage
permission it's gone as HM all it's
making a lot more money I can afford to
give them a little bit more money so I'm
not being greedy here I'm not being
greedy and I'm not cutting them down I'm
not I'm actually Pina I'm a little bit
more money every month to clear their
negative equity a little bit as well so
I'm making a bit crazy to me no no no no
hold on so I'm paying the mortgage but
I'm also give them an extra hundred and
fifty pounds a month because that's
going towards pin that pin more what
more off the mortgage so they're over
pain in the mortgage at the minute just
because that's what they wanted in it
the reason they wanted that is because
they went to my solicitor and the
solicitor that was dealing with this
advise them to do this so the solicitor
was there to take them not me and this
wasn't you being generous you got forced
into it now I was trying to make it look
good I was being generous because I
didn't have to agree to it and so they
went to the solicitor on the solicitor I
said look I think you should ask my pay
more than just the mortgage because then
in four or five years if I say I'm not
gonna buy it at least they've benefited
from me
because I get to benefit from the cash
flow of this property damage making
profits not massive
so it's good for essentially our no
money down property so many rivers like
they want you with the yellow where
you've got anymore vamped and making
about grand on you yeah about nine nine
ten to the point yeah I know it's nine
hundred it's really talented and yeah
but now hundred and ten quid after all
the bills just roughly nine hundred ten
yeah you sure it's not nine hundred and
nine I think it's now hundred ten fifty
five hundred no it's about 910 yeah give
or take you will take its em again that
that's I don't believe in luck I believe
in hard work pays off okay I put a lot
of effort into that property I made a
high-end and we're getting we're getting
actually very good rents for that
property so if we remember working out
the return on investment for thousand
percent yeah yeah but this this first
property that I'm talkin to it was a no
money down deal to get the deal apart
from legal fees legal fees were seven
hundred and fifty pound so I got the
deal no money no money down not normally
750 quid plus part for legal fees that
got me the house I then I could have
rented it as it was and made probably
100 quid a month cash flow
Jamal so I put about eight or nine
thousand pound into it to make it into a
channel so I'm going to get much higher
return
in the area a single late so getting up
at 5:50 so I could have still meet
probably a hundred hundred and
twenty-five pound a month and just let
just let it run and we know I didn't
have to invest eight eight thousand
pound into it but I was gonna tell you
to get that
I won't end you'll be I want a property
I want yeah I want hit jamal's I want
two years and you'll make more money
than if you just left it as is yeah
absolutely it's all about
all of a property with her I just happen
to buy it at the minute and it lets you
test the water so if it doesn't
and for as long as it takes I've added
value to the property I've
and then I will give them my intent in
four years time so in four years time
I'll set them either yes
so my my agreement with them is in four
years time I will say yeah I'm gonna buy
or not buy
I can sell that property to an investor
mm-hmm so I don't I might not be pull
out of it because they just hype
I haven't got the money for the deposit
just hypothetically okay
and the property's red
what would I do with that situation I
could either then go back to the vendors
and say Luke I'm going to pull up
there's the management company on this
day the contracts will change from me to
you and you're going to benefit from the
cash flow do you want to do that if they
say yes they're happy
got cash flow and property it's been
refurb it's in good condition in many
ways a better deal for that that's a
much better deal for them but if they
said no don't work but if they said no
also we want we don't want the property
back we want you to sell it I can in
market that to my list of investors
because I deal with so many investors I
listen
my investor's is buying that property so
so for them the original vendors it's a
done deal they've sold the house
they've just not been paid for it yet
they're a patron and twenty basically
what you're doing is you're taken away
because you've got people in stressful
situations just you solving their
problem yes they can't sell the house
they don't want to manage it they don't
want to and you're just solving it for
them and it and in the end giving them
money it only works in certain
situations it only works when they don't
need the money now but what I will say
with lease options you see a lot of
people advertise and lease options as
sorcerer's online on Facebook and things
that I see this Altima I actually saw it
yesterday by a guy now he's got a lease
option for sale up in the Northeast I
think it was Gateshead somewhere now the
property is current it's laughable
honestly it's utter laughable right okay
so the current today's value sixty
thousand pound he's got it secured and a
lease option in five years for seventy
two thousand pound cash flow nothing the
monthly payment to the vendor is four
hundred and seventy five pounds
the rent is four hundred and seventy
five to five hundred pounds so if it
based he's gonna get twenty five pound a
month positive cash flow do you know his
finder's fee for this property was what
sixteen thousand pound
sixteen nine me what Muppet would buy
that and more probably what Muppet would
try and sell that could even sell that
as a deal it's ridiculous ridiculous we
would buy it like if you've got to say
if you were a bit 16 grand into a lease
option that's worth 60 grand you can buy
the thing now and get our manor guess
for an oil when you see these deal
sources say land deals that just do not
stack up is utter pathetic yeah so just
because these option doesn't mean it's a
good lease no just cuz its lease option
doesn't mean you should take it no I
suppose is its you you wanna be getting
a cash flow don't you was you know
people say oh it's a free house
mmm but it's not a free house because
you do not own it you only own it down
the line when you pay for it
so isn't really a free house and lair
Singh is if it's not cash flow in the
muster point what's the point if it's
not cash flow and how are you gonna
raise the money to buy it in five years
time yeah because property is expensive
in the sense of it's got running cost
it's got mint in this cost free house if
he catch flows so well that you can use
the money from the house to buy at the
end in which case it really is a do not
buy all my lease options do you know
what I do with the money that comes in
every month to save it to buy them it
does I don't see it yeah do not see it
it goes into a bank account that all my
property stuff comes I got it
each property's got a separate bank
account and it comes into the bank out
and that pays the household bills I
don't see it so it just builds up so in
in four or five years time whenever it
comes to buying these properties there's
a pot of money in each account for you
boy with its own with its money
so in theory isn't no money that deal
because the money that I'm gonna be
using to buy that property in five years
is funded by itself yeah
they obviously some of the properties
need a little bit refurb so how about to
put that money in to be a man to begin
with but I'll get that bit up slightly
at the end but my reef Rob money yes
I've had to invest that so there's not
in that but it's not more normally don't
but I'll get that at the back end when I
sell them in or when I benefit from
capital appreciation yeah it's just it
just property investing and if you do it
sensibly it's very profitable if you do
it wrong then ya know it's brilliant
it's great okay I hope you got that we
found that useful that it's a basic
overview of what a lease option is how
it works why it's a win-win it's
important that it is a women has to be
win-win otherwise is it's you know
you're never gonna get the deal you need
to when you go going for these you need
to really understand that it is a
win-win as well so it's now time for
this
[Music]
so in the news this week the times have
done a study on estate agents and
basically what they've found is this a
lot a lot of investors will probably
know this anyway but what they found is
the estate agents are commonly
overvaluing properties yeah and the
reason they do this is because if you
have three estate agents come and look
at your home and one of them says it's
worth 200 yeah and we'll get 200 for it
and the other one says it's worth 160
you're gonna go for the one that says
200 but the thing is is that this estate
agents that are mostly overvaluing are
the ones that charge higher scented fees
so what's ending up happening is you're
going people are going with the
expensive estate agents it's not selling
they're dropping the price to what it's
actually worth to what it's actually
worth yeah
it's selling but then they've tricked
you into into going with them and
therefore paying a higher face very air
misleading isn't it so they're obviously
doing it on purpose because they get
some do they get in the door and then
you're contracted to be there for X
number of months yeah so he goes so the
times analysis of zuper data found that
homeowners who list their property with
any of the 10 estate agents that
overvalue the most would pay on average
double the rate of commission charged by
the teenagers the faily the least it
also found that the largest estate
agents were most likely to over sell
sellers properties and the asking price
on the third of properties was reduced
by an average of twenty three thousand
four hundred quite a jump isn't it it's
interesting because whenever you like
like Simon will last about this from
stage when you when an estate agent sell
and you've date for instance you've got
your property on with an estate agent
and it's not sailing and then you're in
Magnus a year based Easter
explain the hosting to someone and
you're constantly battering the place
down
yeah and then it does sail eventually
it's tell you that houses sale when
they're valued at the right price you do
so when you get houses up
for the properties to sell yeah because
obviously you're having to go for all
the phatal having
let's go back to Hall statistics about
is it a doom and gloom market everyone's
seen its doom and gloom marker whatever
do you not I mean because hobbies so
like they taking ages to sell because
they've been overpriced in the first
place probably if there were the market
value with the sell because let's face
it most people are gonna be buying with
the mortgage yeah they're not buying
cash most I'm a mortgage so if the house
is only worth 150,000 but their state
agents trying to sell for once
you'll see it's only worth 150 so 2 less
and that just causes problems all the
way down the chain yeah two lessons that
I can think of from anything from an
investor's point of view
by the obvious lesson don't be swayed by
the estate agent that says that they can
get the most for it yeah and number two
and this is a big one we've talked about
this before
the market value no yeah yeah yeah
because it is
because people because it's it's not
even it's not even pitched
studies have shown that it clearly
they're valuing it for more than what
actually yeah than what is actually
worth yeah so so you cannot take the
asking price as the market isn't the
second thing into you can't become a
motivated seller so you don't be a
motivated seller in any aspect so yeah
but it was with my buyers now and
investor buying yeah but more yeah but
the thing is if your it comes back to a
little bit too good to be true so if you
get three estate agents come to you and
you're you you know roughly what your
house is worth
I know roughly my house is worth like
three hundred and twenty thousand some
for that if I get in a state agent
comment to me and two of them say yeah
we can get you like 315 320 325 it's
about right if I get one command C we
get 340 for it
most people will go well that one it
says 340 and they're not really look
into things like the percentage of what
the charge and for the rate they'll
think well he's obviously more expensive
because he's Charlie he's got investors
it'll buy it for higher amounts hmm I
know what estate agents are like they're
all where we at we're through our
students when we come to us yesterday
and there and they were showed us a
property deal they'd God yeah and they
said valuation yes
valuation 175 but the agreed the agreed
price 150 and we were like where'd you
get the valuation from the estate a
no we're really into that didn't we yeah
and there was nothing nearby nothing in
the last
eight agents valuation is the key i
think anything is
chose me tells me improves to me yep and
most estate agents are screwed on it and
most of state agencies there's normally
about 10-15 people I would say most
state agencies you've got probably got
two really good people
you've probably got to sort of really
good knowledgeable property experts and
the rest of them not been disrespectful
of state agencies but they're just
selling properties and their job is to
work on Commission to get sale at
property for as high as possible and get
paid their commission most of them don't
actually know what they're talking about
how many times you've been out to
viewing their state agents they are and
they don't have a clue what you're
talking about it's like kind of like on
podcast for example you've got one
person knows what they're talking about
and one person hasn't got a clue what
they're talking about it's the same with
everything it's the same of everything
you've always got one smart someone
smart someone moronic and not my point
being Luke stage agents are not the
experts that everyone thinks they are
they really aren't
no really aren't like that you know you
next time you're out looking at on a
viewing like ask my station what article
four is mostly don't know they think
it's a district in New York they don't
know it's ridiculous and play games with
them say oh yeah what about article 40
is that involved yet article forty forty
1421 article 36 just ask if it's been
enforced and a lot of them over yeah
yeah but there's one action all the
talking about and I'm making it up just
to play games with them and it's
actually quite funny
like for instance another thing I like
to do with mortgage brokers and mortgage
brokers NMM SOI estate agents because
sometimes you get two types on what
estate agents alright you get the state
agent they're basically just sits on the
floor and it says yeah yeah have a look
around whatever and they just play on
the phone and you get the other estate
agent that walks around like that like
they're an expert and they walk past the
damp because they distill yet you need
to look with a little the campaign or
the the things that they just ignore a
lot of stuff but they try and come
across they didn't really know what
they're talking about and then they
start talking about Morgan because
they're trying to sell you their
mortgage broker products and lots of
stuff and I always say no I'm fine of
like a really good mortgage broker and I
make up some random name like I'll say
like yeah I've got a mortgage broker
it's called ABC Finance do you know who
I'm talking about I should you know ABC
and they'll be like yeah yeah we know
them and I'm well how do you know I just
made it up but I'm just playing games
there is obviously fun it probably is
but I see all sorts like I've said I
think that example isn't it yeah
I met this makes it around maybe for
Alliance yeah but there is one so my
point being is they're not the experts
that you think what you say something
stupid
rather than ABC finance where he says
that was just an example for the podcast
I've not said that in real life so what
did you say why won't you said in real
life
I can't mean what it was well you just
say well that he had said rather than
making one up that [ __ ] does exist is
such a bad example so I say property
investors I don't know if you heard of
Alastair Cunningham and they go yeah
yeah I know he's a sidekick on the
podcast and they'll go god no he isn't
I made him up but it's actually true so
come up with a better one
Trent financial services crazy but my
point you can get away with a will
how about BS BS no BS limited I've got a
interestingly I use BS finance do you
know that you know them yeah yeah really
really that is BS finance yeah
no point being they're not the experts
you think they really aren't
most of my just selling houses they're
just trying to sell houses this month
because it's just a passing job for them
which is this fine I'm not criticizing
them and and the sense I'm not
belittling them that way but don't these
bloodiest a a good job the property
experts in make out some of them so why
would you trust a valuation on things
why would I know so many estate agents
and you know how the value stuff go on
how they probably think they can sell it
for literally there's no there's a value
no no it's not you look at market
comparables about how you value
something surely it's surely the values
none were prepared to pay now yes there
is but most of the like for instance I
know lots of estate agents and I
how do you value properties and they say
whatever we feel the most we can get for
it and that's it so you've got no like
no computer system that you put it into
and you walk out comparable as you walk
across or something they don't they let
you go I think we can get 200 for that
and they just put on I said well what
but near buys what bits or nearby
they'll do that because they'll know I
don't think they do man because they'll
have an idea in their head yes what is
roughly worth yeah but this is what
comes back to this article they'll know
the area they'll know what this is where
it comes back to this article and where
what this is saying is there yeah Delia
Libre delivery up in an open yet so
they'll know that that's Adele 3200
they'll tell them to for you explained
yeah so they own all the street vowel is
at 180 200 and obviously it's hard to
just to get them just to get ours to say
yet you can sell my house I'm gonna sign
the contract correct here you the 3
percent 2 percent correct and then they
will drop it back down to I it's
criminal I like the way how he's just
explaining the article that we've been
talking about for last foot thank you
for that that was a very unlikely
enlightening it's at are we gonna do two
three three three three is a magic
number but let's just go with it and
then it wins we kind of need to know
though because it was it's that awkward
you know
no that's end that's just it I tell you
what let's do two and then I will either
end it or I'll say to you right one more
yeah we just want to say how long do we
know so far about 35 some of them are
quite short answers I wish did oh he's
got quick I like a man about forty to
forty right five seven minutes so we've
there's three questions here that we can
answer and two of them are quite quick
there's four actually to them are very
quick to them over longer well let's do
a long one and a short one and then
we'll do a long LaShawn next week as
well right but there's they eight
questions we have to get through for
this oh there's eight okay let's do
three okay rollin
many wave of this kakatiya although
although it is interesting
oh did you get yourself on film saying
that home straight in fact [ __ ] out
there okay so I'm waiting I'm let's go
she did you can edit out now that okay
so it's time for the questions of this
week and we have quite a few so I'm
gonna kick it off going to kick it off
kick it off this is from Dan bull and it
says hey I'm very new to prop D so
please excuse me if this sounds silly
never sound silly Dan in regards to rent
rent lease options what if the tenant
stops paying the rent hmm so what's the
question wife so if the tenant stop
paying pins if the if the tent starts
paying the rent you kick them out and
find a new tenant yep but you're still
liable obviously take a business so if
you take a property on a rent to rent
basis it's no different to rent in a
short if you rent a short and you don't
get any sales you still gotta pay the
rent on the shop if you rent our
business premises you've still got P
they're in so it depends on what you're
doing cuz normally on a rent to rent
normally lease option maybe not but a
rental rents are gonna be HM oh yeah or
service accommodation so service
combination they pay in advance
yeah so you have to worry about that at
all HMO you've got four five tenants
typically so if one of those that was
paying you should still be covering your
your bills but you just need to kick
them any questions not silly but the
fact that you seen rent rent lease
options is irrelevant because it's like
any doesn't what strategy you use them
to buy the property tenants or tenants
if they stopped paying the rent doesn't
matter of as rent to rent off as a by
too late if you're rolling on the rent
you need to go through the legal
channels to chase that rent you need to
evict them but ultimately you're still
responsible for covering the bills of
that property because it's your property
so well if you're if you're getting an
agent to manager they should sort of
take care of that for you really they'll
take care of the legal aspect of it but
ultimately you still you that's paying
the bills so you still have to pay the
bills
yeah awesome good rightist
Alex Cunningham Hey
but killing them I've recently purchased
both Alice's and Samuels book Alice's
book it's phenomenal
you didn't say that I've made up my
questions we both is how do I start off
in property and what are the key points
I need to know to get started if you've
just read my book and Samuels book that
will cover a lot of it I think the next
thing you do is get yourself on property
investors
I'm on this video if you go if you get a
new into property crash course you need
to query it's the place to start I think
absolutely get along to that you've read
both Simon's book and my book
Russell's book is coming up soon read
that as well that would be an awesome
business book but yeah read it 100% what
go on that's one like one that's what
what I'm going to John bleed my audio
book is coming out very soon watches
space and then final question yeah what
happened with that 20 minutes me filming
that yes what happened was the audio the
the recording studio
I booked in it a certain time and the
guy was still in bed when I arrived
which will annoyed me so I told him is
stick it and I tried to find the new
audio and you should do believe so we
had to go back to the guy that was in
bed after him to stick it no I didn't
know
and so I found in our studio but I only
had a two hour slot and I've only got
halfway through it and my schedules been
so busy that not a time to finish it so
is it you reading it yes it is yeah
is it really out that's awkward isn't it
right okay next question
you have to rush that much can we just
well on that for a second you're reading
in your Scottish accent you have to have
subtitles on audio I know there is
subtiles it's called the actual book
though we're gonna have to take his path
nipa gonna have to read it along so
they'll be listening to it reading the
book oh yeah that's what he said that's
what he means
I am everyone keeps I did say I wasn't
gonna read my book as all yes oh no I
said I was gonna get somebody else to do
it but I love your message one a good
laugh by the way right stick on the
YouTube subtitles on this pot yeah I
know
it picks up me perfectly him on the
other hand just like it just goes like
this this is what this is what the
subtitles does it just goes always says
that's basically what happens so it's
quite funny right final question of
today and then we're gonna have lb
people there were people that watch the
the podcast on silent they're watching
at work or something yeah and they'll
just think that you're number two
because they'll be reading it yeah what
what see
they're also people that listen to it
they think you're number two so I
suppose it's not mine that's one right
we both what has been your biggest
headache him
day I'm actually not very well today
I've got a headache so that's been my
biggest headache today
drinking lemon and ginger with honey and
it's it's helping a little bit I'm not
I find beheading
don't point I wouldn't I thought some
milks not good for when you've got head
it is it not no no that's prolly mistake
biggest hurt to know that is my biggest
headache is it just today though that
was neat
today it's well tonight I wasn't my
biggest
good ibuprofen paracetamol yeah I'll
probably say that I presume in property
related I think you might go on hit
Israel okay my biggest headache today is
happened to put up with Russell Leeds
every time we do this podcast do you
don't understand the trauma I go through
I don't they do they watch it everywhere
no seriously and biggest headache is
just over
nine days constant interrupting man
sorry
my biggest hey look together promise you
should go justjust you do it you got
this man it's overcoming my just beliefs
and my objections in my head tell me I
couldn't do what I'm doing that's my
biggest headaches my biggest headache is
dealing with a by refurbished refinance
and having the value and struck out I've
always sorted it in the end but it's
always been a pain in the ass yeah a lot
of people underestimate that went to
Dubai refurb refinance them there yeah
and the sole relying on getting the
valuation that they think they're gonna
get be conservative
so thanks ever so much for tuning in we
will be back same time same place next
week hope you enjoyed the show see you
next week
[Applause]
Oh